robert spencer we are now talking
directly to the taliban and the white
house is full of compliments
that the taliban is being so cooperative
and respectful of the american
negotiators meanwhile the taliban is
executing their enemies left and right
all over afghanistan what is the us
thinking
well you know what's interesting in the
first place about that is that the biden
administration speaks more warmly and
positively about the taliban than it
ever has about the supporters of mr
trump
or about dissenters at school board
meetings and the like uh the taliban is
not
the enemy as far as joe biden has said
even but going back years to the time
that he was vice president
so it's clear that the state department
is following the same failed policies
that it has applied again and again and
again all over the world and that always
fail and that is trying to buy friends
it especially doesn't work in an islamic
context where the recipients of the
american aid see it only as a gesture of
weakness and not as kindness that needs
to be reciprocated so the taliban is
going to get american taxpayer money
and is not going to move a step
toward being friendlier to the united
states these things are all eminently
predictable now but unfortunately the
biden administration doesn't work on the
basis of facts